قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ان الولايات
المتحده ما زالت ملتزمه بمساعده اوكرانيا
في الدفاع عن نفسها بعد مرور
500 يوم على بدء الغزو الروسي واضاف وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه ان الحكومه الروسيه
تظل العقبه الوحيده امام تحقيق سلام عادل
ودائم في اوكرانيا حسب تعبيره
قال وزير الدفاع البولندي ماريوس بلاش
تشاك ان بلاده بدات في نقل اكثر من الف
جندي مع 200 وحده عتاد الى حدودها الشرقيه
وسط تزايد القلق من ان يؤدي وجود مقاتلين
مجموعه فاجنر في بيلاروسيا الى زياده
التوتر على حدودها وزير الدفاع البولندي
ان هذا يدل على استعداد بلاده للرد على
محاولات زعزعه الاستقرار بالقرب من حدودها
وكانت قد اعلنت الاحد الماضي انها سترسل
500 شرطي لتعزيز الامن على حدودها مع
بيلاروسيا